arguably the most ridiculous conspiracy
theory out there claims that planet
Earth is currently being run by a master
race of shape-shifting blood drinking
aliens now I'll admit there are a few
people in positions of power who could
probably pass fills of men under the
right lighting but it should be obvious
to any one with a fully functioning
brain that Earth isn't ruled by highly
intelligent lizards at least not anymore
according to something called the saluan
hypothesis published in the
international Journal of astrobiology in
2018 the science behind it is deadly
serious there's a chance that lizard men
were indeed in charge at some point in
the distant past at its heart the soran
hypothesis is based on a simple question
were we humans the first Advanced
civilization to exist on
Earth